[Music]
what if the flat-earthers were right and
the earth was in fact flat
how would gravity work would we still
have time zones change of seasons with
the conditions for life here on earth
exist at all
this is what if and here's what the
earth would look like if it was flat
first of all forget about walking to its
edge gravity would simply not let you
wait would gravity even be possible on a
flat earth the answer is yes of course
the force of gravity is what keeps our
planet or any other planet together
it's what forms a planet in the first
place in the case of a pancake shaped
Earth the force of gravity would pull
you to the center and will become
stronger as you tried to walk away from
it pulling the top of your body
backwards it would feel as if you were
climbing a hill a hill that was getting
steeper and steeper and steeper by the
time you reach the edge down and behind
you would be the same direction sound
weird how about water being sucked into
the center of the earth or diagonal
trees growing in the opposite direction
of gravity's pull and then there's the
Sun how would a Flat Earth behave in
space one Flat Earth theory is that the
Sun revolves around the earth not the
other way around
what if the Sun orbited the earth just
like the moon does in that case you'd
never suffer jetlag because there'd be
no such thing as time zones the Sun
would light up both the top and the
bottom of the planet this would mean
constant light no day and night cycle
also no seasons or solar eclipses the
Sun itself would have to be much smaller
otherwise it would burn the earth to a
crisp
it would probably fry the planet anyway
as there would be no geomagnetic field
to protect Earth from its radiation the
geomagnetic field is generated in the
solid core of the earth and keeps our
atmosphere from escaping without it
cosmic rays would bombard our bodies
causing everything from cancer to DNA
damage the oceans would escape into
space and so with the air and all our
oxygen
but let's assume that a flat earth had
an alternative to our magnetic field
this way you'd still be alive to notice
some of the strange Flat Earth effects
like your shadow say you had a friend
just as tall as you but they lived a
thousand miles away on a sunny day your
shadows would be the very same length
because unlike here on a spherical earth
the sun's rays would hit both of you at
the same angle and if you two were to
meet up traveling would turn out very
different let's take a map introduced by
the Flat Earth Society yeah the one that
shows the Arctic at the center and
Antarctica as an ice wall around the
edges in this world it would take you 32
hours to fly from Australia to Argentina
did we mention there be no GPS
satellites wouldn't be able to orbit a
Flat Earth leaving humanity with no
navigation and no synchronized time
this means no ATMs no credit cards no
high-speed stock market transactions on
the bright side with a good pair of
binoculars you could see Dubai's Burj
Khalifa from any part of the flat world
but let's be honest you don't need to
build your own rocket to see that the
earth is not flat the evidence is all
around us
[Music]